[Music]
when i get up she swears that she don't
hear it
says that i'm as quiet
i comb my hair
to throw some water on my face
back out of the stillness of our house
lately my patience
[Music]
isn't your
supply nothing good seems to ever come
from all this work
no matter how hard i try
[Music]
you know i believe in the sun i ain't no
backsliding
my people were told they'd prosper in
this land
still i know some
who've never seen the ocean
except one foot on a velvet bed of sand
but they've got their treasure
laying away
up high
where there might be many mansions
but when i look up
all i see is sky
maybe it's the kitten by
it gets right underneath
[Music]
maybe it's the stuff it takes to get up
in the morning
and put another day
in the sun that holds you to the
kittens good
[Music]
green ribbon front doors
dishwater days
this whole town is tied to the torso
of god's mysterious ways
maybe it's the kitten by
it gets right
[Music]
but maybe it's the stuff it takes to get
up
in the morning
and put another day
in the sun that keeps you standing where
you
should so put another day
in the sun and hold on
[Music]
all right
felt